una partícula se mueve a lo largo de la
curva x 16 por lo que la coordenada y
incrementa déjenme subrayar eso la
coordenada e incrementa a una tasa
constante de 2 unidades por minuto eso
significa que la tasa de cambio de jake
con respecto a t es igual a 2 cuál es la
magnitud en unidades por minuto del
vector de velocidad de la partícula
cuando la partícula se encuentra en el
punto 44 bueno x es igual a 4 y ya es
igual a 4 ok pero primero recordemos que
es un vector de velocidad miren nuestra
velocidad está en función del tiempo y
tendrá dos componentes pero cuál es la
tasa de cambio en la dirección x y cuál
es la tasa de cambio en la dirección y
bueno la tasa de cambio en la dirección
x es
x dt y la tasa de cambio en la dirección
de este y dt y nos dicen que deje de t
es una constante es igual a dos unidades
por minuto pero no nos están pidiendo el
vector de velocidad por sus componentes
sino que nos están pidiendo la magnitud
nos piden la magnitud del vector de
velocidad de la partícula entonces si
tenemos un vector supongamos que tenemos
el vector a este vector tiene los
componentes de hice así que la magnitud
de este vector que lo pueden encontrar
escrito así o así con dos barras y esto
proviene del teorema de pitágoras la
magnitud del vector a es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada más se cuadrada
por lo tanto en este caso es la raíz
cuadrada del componente x al cuadrado
más el componente y al cuadrado entonces
si queremos calcular la magnitud de
nuestro vector de velocidad
es decir la magnitud del vector de
velocidad de la partícula bueno podemos
decir que la magnitud de p en función de
t es igual a la raíz cuadrada del
componente x al cuadrado que en este
caso es la tasa de cambio de x con
respecto al tiempo al cuadrado más el
componente que al cuadrado que en este
caso es la tasa de cambio de g con
respecto a t al cuadrado y cómo podemos
resolver esto cómo podemos calcular
estas dos cosas bueno ya sabemos que la
tasa de cambio de y con respecto a t es
una tasa constante de dos unidades por
minuto entonces ya sabemos que esto es
igual a 2 por lo tanto todo esto es
igual a 4 y como calculamos la tasa de
cambio de x con respecto a t bueno para
eso podemos usar la ecuación original
que describe la curva y podemos sacar la
derivada de ambos lados de la ecuación
con respecto a
y eso nos dará una ecuación que
involucra a xy con de x dt y d jeter
entonces hagamos eso tenemos que xy es
igual a 16 y vamos a sacar la derivada
de esto con respecto a t lo escribiré de
otro color vamos a sacar la derivada con
respecto a t de todo esto y la derivada
con respecto a t de este lado ahora del
lado izquierdo tenemos un producto de
dos funciones entonces mire si decimos
que x es una función de t y gec también
es una función de t aquí podemos aplicar
la regla del producto y la regla de la
cadena esto es igual a la derivada de la
primera función la derivada de x con
respecto a x que es 1 por la derivada de
x con respecto a t
la segunda función es decir porque más
la primera función que es x por y cuál
es la derivada de y con respecto a que
claro es igual a uno y después cuál es
la derivada de y con respecto a t bueno
es igual a tg dt y eso es igual a la
derivada de una constante y eso es igual
a cero ahora cómo podríamos simplificar
esto bueno en realidad ya no necesitamos
simplificarlo mejor simplemente vamos a
sustituir los valores y calculemos de x
dt sabemos que de 7 es igual a todos y
nos piden la magnitud del vector de
velocidad de la partícula cuando la
partícula se encuentra en el punto 44
entonces cuando x es igual a 4 x es
igual a 4 y es igual a 4 que es igual a
4 bueno
esta es la ecuación que podemos usar
pues sólo tenemos una incógnita que es
la tasa de cambio de x con respecto a t
en el punto 4 4 entonces si resolvemos
esto podemos sustituirlo aquí y calcular
la magnitud del vector de velocidad
vamos a escribirlo
aquí tenemos 4 de x
dt más 4 x 28 y esto es igual a 0
entonces si restamos menos 8 en ambos
lados nos queda 4dx dt y al dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 4 nos
queda que de x dt es igual a menos 2 por
lo tanto en este punto el cambio en x
con respecto a t es igual a menos 2 y si
lo elevamos al cuadrado
nos queda 4 por lo tanto la magnitud de
nuestro vector de velocidad es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de 44 que es igual a 8
y eso es igual a 4
por 2 entonces esto es igual a 2 por la
raíz cuadrada de 2 unidades por minuto
esta es la magnitud del vector de
velocidad